as a comic who's early in the game
it's uh it's definitely one of those
things where
it's difficult because you don't have
the tool set and you don't know your
voice yet
early on and you're just kind of
scrambling but
the longer that you're into comedy and
the more you know yourself and the more
you know your voice the easier it is and
then if you're just a funny person
you'll be successful at the show and
even you're seeing
and it's funny to be like yeah just i
just have this show
stand up on the spot but then this is
like joe rogan burke chrysler like
whitney cummins like this is
the elite of elite of comedians you're
seeing perform nightly
at the comedy store yeah what
what have you learned from just even
being around that level of success
unpack it
uh i learned a of you know a valuable
lesson even last night um i was
literally about to go on stage at the
comedy store
and i got bumped by dave chappelle
and i waited for like an hour
and then he brought up ti and he and t.i
are like riffing and singing ti songs on
stage
and i'm just sitting in the back like am
i am i still
am i still going on next and uh they
came over to me and they're like
it's not happening dude he's like doing
too much time yeah
and this is kind of a lesson like no
matter where
where you are like where like how you're
feeling like
you're gonna get checked repeatedly over
and over
throughout your career like i've been
feeling pretty good lately
having some cool stuff going on is this
like as like a sign
like yo
keep working so you don't have to be
bumped
by this kind of thing yeah because you
know
like stay humble keep your head down
keep working and good things will happen
this is like i mean there's another like
you get little ego checks all along the
way
not that i've ever really had personally
any problems with
like having a big ego or whatever but
you see it happen to different comedians
around you and stuff like that
yeah totally yeah that's probably
attributed to
your success as well don't you think uh
yeah i i i guess so i don't know just
like not having an ego
and just like i've done over 140 of
these interviews and
a common theme for successful people is
almost like
just be cool yeah just like be easy to
work with
yeah because i mean there's there's so
many people out there that
are talented and professional like if
you happen to be talented but you're
hard to work with like
you're gonna phase out like it's like
nobody
like yeah it's a very short-term
short-sighted person that's like i'm
gonna do me like i'm
like i like i'm gonna do it this way and
like i'm not gonna care
like like how this is affecting other
people and then like the people who are
fun to be around and easy to work with
and
and cool like those are the people who
have longevity
in this field or any career really
hot breath